so und heute meine damen und herren
machen wir das hier mal ganz anders
statt kaum noch sinken der
infektionszahlen oder ausgangssperre in
flensburg einfach mal was schönes ja
weil man sonst durchdreht die leute
wollen mal was schönes was auf harry und
merken erwarten ihr zweites kind da ist
also bald harry hol schon mal den
kinderwagen wegen der rag das hat ja
noch immer zu seinem assistenten harry
klein gesagt gespielt von fritz wepper
der ja später wissen viele nicht
nee kann man nicht mal eine sendung ohne
drecks corona machen einfach nur was
schönes ja ist ja gut
corona ja wie beschreibt man die
aktuelle stimmung bei uns im land
schwierig irgendetwas zwischen müde und
trotzig wir wissen es droht eine dritte
welle aber es soll jetzt einfach vorbei
seien verdammt noch mal
man sehnt sich nach früher früher als
zum beispiel der politische
aschermittwoch der csu
auch schrecklich war aber nicht so
trostlos wie heute ein herzliches grüß
gott nach oberfranken wo sind die
oberfranken
ich sitz hier im wohnzimmer im csu
wohnzimmer wo sind die niederbayern
liebe freunde
trotzdem ist die stimmung schwierig ich
denke übrigens ich geb's zu cola light
das macht alles keinen spaß
genau das wird man übrigens auch nach 16
jahren unter kanzler schröder sagen es
macht alles keinen spaß
nix macht mir mehr spaß es gibt wieder
grenzkontrollen mitten in europa zb an
der grenze zu tirol wegen der mutation
ja gut es muss vielleicht sein aber es
ist doch trotzdem traurig ehrlich leute
haben wir noch irgendwas schönes was man
senden könnte irgend eine meldung die
mut macht sachsens ministerpräsidenten
die michael kretschmer sagt auch der
osterurlaub der müsse in diesem jahr
ausfallen
natürlich ausreiseverbote die
zweitschönste ostdeutsche tradition nach
räuchermännchen aus dem erzgebirge
vielleicht hat herr kretschmann ja sogar
recht aber lasst uns doch wenigstens
noch fünf wochen die illusion wir
könnten ostern mal irgendwohin warum
sagt der mann jetzt schon ostern ab und
wer erklärt das den osterhasen
ich mach das
die häschenschule 2021 nun beginnt die
erste stunde häschen haben wehren konnte
seht wie ihre augen strahlen wenn sie
lernen eier malen
keiner sagt den armen hasen mustern ist
längst abgeblasen und am ende landet ihr
leider alle in hartz4 tja und was
richtiges gelernt
die hasen so und jetzt aber liebe
zuschauer wirklich mal was positives ab
märz können wir alle kostenlose
schnelltests machen und dann kommen
irgendwann wohl auch heißt es selbst
tests für zu hause
ja wo man nur noch gurgelt oder spuckt
die sage ich könnten der game changer
werden selbst mit einer gewissen
fehlerquote und fischte in jedem fall
die hoch ansteckenden menschen raus dass
du ne super sache
wir haben hier einen test den mann
überschreiben können mit der überschrift
spucken kann jeder stimmt das kann jeder
im gegensatz zu doktorarbeiten alleine
schreiben
ich meine klar bei den kostenlosen
schnelltests da fragt man sich schon
warum haben wir die nicht längst in
tübingen gibt die seit ende november mit
großem erfolg hätten wir längst haben
können auch hier übrigens der moment wo
angela merkel einfällt dass sie
vergessen hat eine echte test strategie
zu entwickeln hatte macht hier konnte im
moment da fällt sie ein gut in
wirklichkeit hat sie da nur ihre maske
am rednerpult liegen lassen aber die
szene passt einfach zu allem
[Musik]
ja die jungen leute nennen das wohl ein
gift extra aufgeschrieben natürlich ist
kein politiker schuld an mutationen die
den lock down in die länge ziehen
gleichzeitig werden lockerungs druck und
ungeduld im land immer größer da möchte
man weder politiker noch virologe seien
am allerwenigsten politiker und virologe
karl lauterbach berichtet diese woche
von einer regelrechten hass welle die im
netz entgegen schwappt eine klar muss
man nicht alles gut finden was der mann
sagt natürlich nicht aber wütend sein
auf den überbringer der schlechten
nachricht friedhof ist das denn bitte
wenn wir zu früh lockern kann es also
sein dass die inzidenz für das
ursprüngliche virus weiter sinkt aber im
hintergrund eine mutation welle ins
exponentielle wachstum geht wie gesagt
wenn wir das machen deutschland
inzwischen ganz dicht auf dem niveau
eines siebenjährigen absolut infantil
selbst wenn natürlich alle keinen bock
mehr haben auf gruner und auf locker
hass im netz wirklich sehr sehr
bedauerlich dass das mehrfach
angekündigte neue gesetz der groko gegen
hate speech immer noch nicht da ist und
wozu hass im internet im wirklichen
leben führen kann muss man am jahrestag
von hanau wohl kaum erklären
aber wie antwortet man auf hass mails
schwierig manche kann man ignorieren
andere muss man sicher anzeigen und aus
dem rest macht meine lesung professor
karl lauterbach bahrenfeld ausgewählte
riss lyrik guten abend zunächst amerika
fragt warum läuft der eigentlich noch
frei herum da seine gute frage ralf
tatsächlich habe ich meine sozialen
kontakte weitgehend eingeschränkt aber
es ist ein gerücht dass der einzige
verbleibende sozialkontakt noch markus
lanz wäre etwas breiter aufgestellt ist
es dann doch noch
lori meint wer ist selbst der größte
moment kann ich nur sagen also wenn ich
ein mutant wäre dann wäre ich anstecken
und das einzige was bei mir noch
ansteckend geblieben wäre wäre dann der
humor den ich mir auch in dieser phase
nicht nehmen lasse michael m fragt kann
die gleiche nicht mal einer weg räumen
nun ja zunächst hier bin ich ich bin
keine leiche ich bin noch unterwegs aber
der ein oder andere der sich hier nicht
impfen lässt wer könnte demnächst eine
leiche seien mit oder ohne crack konsum
das alles heute abend um 23.30 bei
[Musik]
karl lauterbach heute wollte er im
impfzentrum leverkusen als arzt
mithelfen aber die polizei hat ihn wegen
angekündigter proteste und
sicherheitsbedenken abgeraten
und eines ist ganz sicher in einer welt
in der virologen so angefeindet werden
ist sprachliche sensibilität wirklich
das gebot der stunde
hier exemplarisch vorgemacht von einem
fußballlehrer wir finden es so langsam
kann man die sogenannten experten gar
nimmer gar nicht mehr hören ja auch herr
lauda bach ganz ehrlich jetzt wird weil
sich ja gerade angesprochen haben er hat
immer zu irgendetwas was zu sagen ja
hansi jetzt ist aber der sogenannte
korona experte lauterbach von beruf
epidemiologe das macht ihn in gewisser
weise schon zum experten während du
hansi kein epidemiologe bist was man
schon daran erkennen dass du hansi heißt
an sie heißen schlagersänger
wellensittiche und du schützenhilfe
kriegt der hansi diese woche allerdings
von einem der wichtigsten politischen
köpfe des landes von stefan effenberg
zitat efe der fußball hat vieles richtig
gemacht was die politik nicht zu 100%
hinbekommt der fußball muss als vorbild
für die politik dienen sagte ja und was
soll ich sagen der fc bayern nimmt diese
anregung direkt auf und tritt für mich
wie sensationsmeldung der woche
tatsächlich bei der bundestagswahl im
september als partei an sebastian
pufpaff generalsekretär der fcp der
neuen fc bayern partei herr papa was
kann denn die politik von euch lernen
drei worte mir sagen mir bayerisch für
so dicke eier mit der bajuwarischen
muttermilch aufgesogen das
selbstbewusstsein gut andere sagen
arroganz die politiker da in berlin die
wollen immer gemocht werden die wollen
liebe und das ist falsch
nur user wollen gemacht werden wer
erfolg hat können sie mal googeln erfolg
der wehr ist ein mann ja deshalb heißt
es auch erfolg sonst dieses sieht ist
egal
und der kann sich damit nehmen die noch
offene lederhose hier unser karl heinz
macht's vor
er hat vorgeschlagen konkret
fußballprofis er zu impfen
man wolle sich 20 vorträgen aber so
könne der fußball als vorbild einen
gesellschaftlichen beitrag leisten
wir wollen uns zwar nicht vordringen
aber doch der könne nur der alte uhren
schmuggler beziehungsweise deren sohn ja
da brauchen sie jetzt noch gar nicht so
lange wieder zu gucken herreweghe insel
nach leistung nie denn sonst wird
übrigens auch unser neues wahlplakat
platz sauer hier kommt der recorder ist
das ist der bayern spirit extrem
unsympathisch aber auf eine humorige art
und weise nehmen sie nun mal unseren
kleinen hansi er hat einen ganz
wunderbaren mutterwitz hiermit geht es
oftmals so dass ich oder habe das gefühl
dass jeder so aus der situation
möglichst sein profit schlagen kann wie
kann er bei der nächsten wahl vielleicht
den punkt oder die prozentpunkte mehr
machen da brauche ich aber die zeitlupe
ich habe kein witz gehört
sie redet über politiker die nur auf
profit aus sind
wer von einer riesigen versorgt sitzt
und glücklich mich einlassen unter
anderem mit qatar airways der
staatlichen airline eines emirats in dem
die sklaven stadien bauen und trotzdem
haben wir deren logo auf dem trikot
sie sind noch eine spaßbremse oft das
nennt man realpolitik klar man kann zum
beispiel sagen die chinesen
die stecken die unruhen ins arbeitslager
oder man sagt eva funktion tank von 37
jahren von leoni
ich wünsche euch alles gute
im jahr des ochsen sie hörten die
neujahrsansprache des kommenden kanzlers
alles gute im jahr des ochsen versteht
und was wären so die politischen ziele
der fc bayern partei gewinnen halt wie
immer
wir gucken uns an was die anderen
parteien für talente haben und dann
kaufen wir die vom markt für diesen
christian lindner zum beispiel würde ich
bis zu 300 euro zahlen und das kabinett
steht eh schon uli hoeneß finanzen ist
klar und olli kahn als
verteidigungsminister ist eine
traumbesetzung da gibt der alle putin
die krim aber nach drei minuten
freiwillig zurück daher bitte ich sie
liebe mitbürger nein quatsch ich befehle
wählen sie am 26 september die fc bayern
partei und nun sehen wir die neue hymne
der bundesrepublik deutschland fc bayern
hallo leute ich bin's der heute-show
[Musik]
hersteller
wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß und liebten
- wollt dann abonniert jetzt den kanal
was zur hölle ist minimal hersteller